You have just seen how to add context and
narrative to your data through the process of visualization.
We've also seen how journalists traditionally do this.
And how data journalism reimagines this process.
>> You also learned how important it is to verify and validate your data.
You learned a little bit about the different types of biases that can exist,
such as data bias, author bias and reader bias.
>> Now that we're comfortable with different types of narrative
structures within visualizations, let's see how we can apply these to our own.
We'll use interaction and
animation to add a new depth of field to our particular visualization.
In this case, the World Cup example.